young all right well welcome everybody
welcome back to the people who are
who've been here before and welcome to
everybody who is new
there's also Marcus Sherman flowing
around somewhere Oh in the back
we are the co-organizers of Paideia
annarbor as always we'd love to
acknowledge people so numb focus for
sponsoring our meetup as well as TD
Ameritrade which is where I work is a
space that you're in for hosting the
location the venue and also - for
sponsoring the food so make sure that
you show your appreciation whenever you
can a couple important points emergency
exits for those who are new in case of
emergency there's an exit right here and
one to the right as you move up the
front doors here we're always looking
for speakers not not only for our
lightning talks but for our monthly
meetup talks so if you missed you for
the Lightning talks please feel free to
reach out to us and or just talk to us
directly if you like to give a talk and
always provide feedback things that
we're doing right but more importantly
things that we're doing wrong okay could
improve upon we'd love to hear that
feedback either email us or send us a
tweet at party to Ann Arbor or send us
an email at patty Ann Arbor at gmail.com
because of the nature of the lightning
talks we might allow one question if any
what do you think okay how about we do
this if you end earlier than your 10
minutes then you you get one question
yeah but if you take up your full time
then no question and then is gonna be
monitoring this and he will play a
special song as you've gone over yeah so
you will know what that song is so yeah
no question try not to have any
questions and also remember that this is
a plural space so please clean up after
yourselves because of the food if you
see some trash how about a quote of
contact because we do have new
here I'd like to read the paw data code
of conduct where everybody especially
our speakers to know that I am hoping
that you have read it and acknowledges
but pod unit is dedicated to providing a
harassment free meeting experience for
everyone regardless of gender sexual
orientation gender identity and
expression disability physical
appearance body size race or religion we
do not tolerate harassment of meeting
participants in any form all
communication should be appropriate for
professional audience including people
of many different backgrounds sexual
language and imagery is not appropriate
for any of our meetup events be kind to
others do not insult or put-down other
attendees behave professionally remember
that harassment and sexist races or
exclusionary jokes are not appropriate
for high data attendees violating these
rules may be asked to leave the meetup
at the sole discretion of the meetup
organizers thank you all for the help
helping to make this a welcoming and
friendly event for everybody so thank
you a quick icebreaker because we want
people to be able to leave here at least
having known somebody so today either
turn to somebody on your left or knit
right introduce yourselves and either
tell them your favorite sport to play or
the your favorite sport to watch go
ahead
[Music]
so hopefully you will you will be able
to leave here today at least one other
person at this Meetup as always we like
to also point out a data science I guess
month in data science this isn't really
something that just came out it came out
uh it's been out for a while but I think
was pulping source recently so there's
this thing called Q PI or QP which is a
drop-in replacement for numpy but that
leverages GPUs right so you can check
that out
people have tried to solve this problem
there's also other tools like accelerate
coming out of anaconda but definitely
check this out people have been playing
with this there's a lot of news about it
and also I want to point out also thanks
to again - - for the food but midas is
hosting their data driven world
potentials of pitfalls it's a it's a -
symposium tomorrow Wednesday October 11
at the University of Michigan so if you
want to check that out I think there's a
couple people here that are will be
attending we will be attending I know
Brandon Ewbank from our TD Ameritrade
and also his boss Beaumont bands will be
part of some panel there tomorrow so
check that out also
I don't know Alexander or I know Dan
Russell is in here but the a - deep
learning group they have an annual deep
learning I guess day or two meeting it's
going to be at the unit on the
University campus so definitely a search
for that and sign up for their event
it's held on September I'm sorry
Saturday November 18th and it's between
10 a.m. and 7 p.m. so I have a bunch of
people giving talks about deep learning
we're gonna learn more last but not
least and I know Stephanie is here over
there right but there's an advertisement
for Ann Arbor Day today
which is hosted by the University of
Michigan School of Information I've
participated in the last few years as a
way to volunteer
so it's partnering up with so and our
data dive the group at the University
that works with local nonprofits across
Michigan to help them solve some sort
data problem this year they will be
hosting a series of boot camps in the
morning for people who are getting into
data science and then I think by about
lunchtime you can take part in their
sort of data hackathon is probably the
best way to put it it's a lot of fun a
lot of great energy and good food so go
check it out and it's going to be on
Saturday November 11 and you can sign up
at learn more at eight to day-to-day
work did I miss anything Stephanie yes
there's always TD Ameritrade we are
hiring and there point out my buddy here
branding you back to and put your hand
up so Brendan is one of the hiring
managers so if you're looking for a job
he's hiring for a bunch of different
roles I think you'll see some job
posting papers to his right along the
window there but if you might have
placed some as that that's it okay but
definitely reach out to and stick around
afterwards and talk to Brandon if you're
interested in any roles we're hiring for
Mikey we're looking for a sort of a
consultant level developer but for doing
research and development on the advanced
technology team here at to the
Ameritrade and also a plug for our next
event we've got David Rogers from the
sight machine a lo a company here in I
guess they have a an office here in Ann
Arbor and the title of this talk is
delivering data products for operations
and this is on Tuesday November 14 so
we're trying to switch to Tuesday's for
our meetups so please sign up for that
and with that good so our first speaker
is Olga you'll have to help me with your
last name give it a try Ava and our next
speaker is Michael Lantz
who's gonna be on deck so we'll pop this
over to you
so hi everyone my name is Olga and I'm
from Michigan State University I'm
finishing my PhD in economics Oh green
and I'm an economist but all centered
interested in data science so I would
like to show you the economist also do
some cool research and maybe you will
get history interested so the topic of
representation hot or not how facial
attractiveness affect wages so let's
start you guys maybe not know but we
economists know that your wage is
actually affected by your height your
weight and your attractiveness and when
we talk about attractiveness it's
usually measured on a five-point scale
like from one to five like one being not
attractive at all and five being
extremely attractive and the United
States is being estimated that the
beauty premium is about ten fifteen
percent it means that more attractive
workers actually having ten fifteen
percent higher wages than less
attractive ones it doesn't seem fear but
this beauty premium actually exists and
if you I if you ask like why it exists
there are several explanation for this
beauty premium so one is employer
discriminations it may be the case that
just employers like to hire a more
attractive workers another one may be
consumer discrimination it's also
possible that customers they prefer to
do with one attractive employees and
another explanation
it's Occupational crowding so this idea
is like more attractive people they will
search themself into occupation with
higher wages and they will result in
high wages compared with workers that
are less attractive well research show
that the that number one reason for
beauty premium tip see it's actually
employer discrimination employers do
like to hire more attractive workers and
that's number one reason well but the
question is why flirt discriminate like
why they doing this we can see for sure
but some love experiments suggest that
more attractive workers they are more
confident and they have better aural
skills so that may be the reason why
they negotiate better and
they expect very high wages another
reason it's also employers wrongly
considered more attractive workers is
more able so they think that they
appease these people more just because
then we're able but then the reason is
like they just weren't attractive I'm
using data from Russia because there are
many attractive especially female
workers in Russia and I scraped my data
from internet I'm using yeah I'm Russian
so I can say that I'm using I'm using
Russian on my job board headhunter it's
the biggest online online job board in
Russia there are a lot of resumes and
job s available on this website so I
spread to follow information
I collect desired job titles and wages
so it's kind of similar structure like
LinkedIn so but when you search for a
job you specify like what job title you
are searching for and what we age you
would like to receive and also some
people put profile for us so I'm using
both of it and my research question is
whether more attractive workers asking
for high wages in their resume compares
with compared with just the same workers
that are less attractive or with the
average market wage this is just to show
you how how my data look like so this is
typical profile available you see there
is a picture of a person there is
information about the person there is a
job title and the monthly wage the humid
likes to receive so I know a lot about
about these people so that's why I can
compare I can basically find two workers
it's exactly the same they have all the
same experience the same education the
only thing that's different it's like
how they like contract if they are cells
it stalls information and I also have
the job add salt in the job as I see the
description of a job and also the wage
that they would like to pay you for this
job
so so far this research is like all
about economics and you may ask yourself
like why she's like it's data science
meetup like it's all about economics
well I would like to introduce some data
science is this research because I would
like to use machine learning to predict
attractiveness it's like I have a huge
data set and there is no way I can
manually rate all these pictures even if
I want it so that's why I would like to
train the models that will predict the
effectiveness for every picture for me
this
pictures out gonna give you an idea how
I'm doing this so first I'm detecting
faces so these people they put their
photos and I need to detect faces if I
see more than one face I don't consider
these pictures because there is no way I
can guess who is a job seeker at this
picture so but if there is one one
person I have 68 facial emerge so facial
landmarks is some crucial points on your
face it's like a corner of your eye it's
a tip of the nose so it's the points
that actually tell me like how structure
your face is it's not the best way how I
can do it but this is just a way to
start like I'm starting my research so
if you guys have any other suggestions
out you're very welcome to fear I have
the 68 Fisher landmarks and but Lamers
just pours right they have coordinates
but I can just use this landmarks in my
model so what I do I take pay rise
distances so this is all the ratios so
it gives me some idea about how what the
ratio in your face like what is the
distance between eyes like how big is
your nose and like stuff like that and I
have a lot of features out there and I
can use them all so I'm using principle
component analysis to reduce the
dimensionality of my feature space and
what was the result
well I just started so I trained my
model and I got accuracy of 60% it's not
what I was hoping for and it's
definitely not what I want to have in my
final paper but I think it's a nice try
like for the beginning it's better than
random gas which is only 20% and the
most important part is like but whether
actual more attractive people are having
higher wages well in Russia I found it
more attractive female workers asking
for 15 20 % higher wages than less
attractive ones this is compared to the
market wages so far I found no evidence
of the existence of beauty premium for
man I don't know maybe I will find it
later or not so there is something going
on about men like they really don't care
like how attractive they are when they
hire but it's definitely for a female
worker in Russia it's better to be
attractive so yeah this is what I found
because this is just a start
I would like to perceive is my research
so I would like to collect
labels and use crowdsourcing for that so
I consider using Amazon Mechanical Turk
so that I have a lot of pictures a
gradient so that my model hopefully may
give me better accuracy and I also
consider using convolutional neural net
and again like I need a lot of like
pictures like that already rated to use
this kind of method and if you have any
suggestion any job offers I'm on the job
market
you're very welcome this is my email and
we can chat after this presentation
thank you so much yeah so far I used so
far I use data set like academic
datasets it's like they give you home
like the user's training and also rated
myself yeah but this is just for the
beginning like I don't trust myself I
don't feel like I'm objective but this
one is this crowdsourcing to average so
ideally I would like for every picture I
would like every picture to be rated by
at least like four people two men and
two women
this is Michael Lantz talking about
school data analysis automation so I'd
like to preface this by saying that
working at a school district for which
I've done about for about ten years now
and five which before I was a teacher at
the middle school level I can tell you
that in the average school district
unless you're at the county level or ISD
level there's not a lot of data science
going on which probably is not very
surprising to you so I so with that I
just want to say that when I say that we
don't have a sequel server or anything
like that even we just have you know a
directory of CSVs that's that's all we
have really um given that background
I'll continue so I was a teacher once
upon a time and then I got promoted to
doing data analysis on student test
scores where I worked and I quickly
realized that my job would involve a lot
of reporting external reporting for
state accountability for example annual
educational reports also internal
reporting for example grouping students
or helping to make instructional
decisions and even rostering students
for computerized testing and so they
presented some some challenges one being
time the time that it took cuz it was
just me and it's still just me by the
way the repetition right and and
dissemination so especially cuz I
started with Excel which I'll get into
shortly with data the main challenges
seem to be acquiring and this is kind of
universal at the school district level
right I think if I can say that
acquiring the data standardizing it into
one table from different assessment
sources visualizing sharing the data and
then using it what to do with it
so when I first started I was using
Excel if that was the best thing ever
like and I had all these formulas and
people would call me all the time like
and say hey can you do the index match
for me because I don't know ten years
later I still get phone calls to the
index match because people don't look at
my tutorials but that's another issue
altogether um so and then I got into AI
software I thought that was amazing and
you know it still is helpful to some
degree however
you know we had there's training for
myself and for the the users
quote-unquote for administrators and
teachers and then you have to pay for
the accounts and the licenses and you
know you probably understand how that
works so in education there's a lotta
it's not a ton of funding for things
like that
as you probably know and so my
introduction to Python was really out of
laziness because you know let's say
there's a test that students take in the
fall and spring and let's say you're a
third-grade student you took a math test
in the fall and you actually took it
three times the first time you vomited
on the keyboard the second time you're
just really tired and a third time that
was you know the good but when I look at
the data I don't know which is which
right so I have to have criteria and the
criteria on which I choose one of those
course so it would take me like days in
Excel and or I'd do like a an array
formula it would take you know crash my
computer basically and so I discovered
pandas and I think it's a when I was
done at two weeks it took me to write it
I did a lot of a lot of this right and
then after a while I think the script
now takes seven seconds and I still use
it to this day so that to me is like I
was sold right after that so and I want
to convey to other I try to convey to
other educators how this is but you know
index match is like the pinnacle of data
usage for the nearest five square miles
I'm guessing I don't know anyway so I
got really into these different packages
and this Seabourn matplotlib
I became a visualization analyst for a
year and a half at Trinity Health in
healthcare so I really got into
visualization I got a little bit
obsessed yes this is my license plate
unless if you want a picture next to it
later let me know and so and so anyways
um what it is so the question how has
Python helped in my situation given
everything I just explained well for
acquiring data obviously there's an API
you can connect but I don't want to get
I don't wanna get blacklisted from the
state of Michigan for the department
occation website if I shouldn't we
talked about this right now
anyway the point is there's some issues
so not quite there yet
but yeah I don't really download data
frequently enough for it to bother me
that much so I haven't really pursued it
but maybe someday
standardizing data so this is probably
really basic to most of you but this is
like rocket science in most school
districts because when you have the data
like this you can do it's hard to really
express how much time this saves and how
much more you can do with it so they
have different various assessments
student level data all combined into one
they all have scale scores sometimes
have percentiles sometimes they have
error scores from different windows so
that's kind of the scaffolding right and
that sets me up for the next step which
would be visualizing so I start with a
prototype I'll iterate over schools
grades and subgroups I'll adjust for
variations so for example if you have a
school as in that plot that you're
making a horizontal bar chart and you've
got a school that's K through 12 and oh
that's K through 8 so if you have K
through 8 bars there's less than K
through 12 but if you have a text or a
title that's dependent on the
y-coordinate then it's going to adjust
it you don't want to adjust so you want
to be you know so you have to put some
parameters so things like that I have to
do I guess it's pretty universal and
then saving it to PNG and CSV file now
some people would say that you know we'd
like to interact with it and my response
would be we had that set up before but
nobody logged in because they want
another account so the solution was to
push this out to shared folders and yes
you can't interact with it but there's a
CSV file that goes exactly with it and
maybe okay what I'm ready for it so so
here's an example um an honor of John
Hunter I wish they would make it John
Hunter elementary school but I love that
pilot so if we look at section a of
grade five of math from the end of a map
test fall 17 the first thing that I
would do in the process would be to make
a graph like this for example and this
would be helpful because if I'm a fifth
grade teacher for section a and I'm
looking at my math students or my
students for math scores it might be
interested that there's a multi-modal
distribution here because for
differentiation right and pacing
prioritizing end up and the curriculum I
want to know where the the split is to
help those students and then I might
clean it up a bit and this is actually
m-step math scores looking at not
proficient partially proficient
proficient and advanced so this is
helpful because you might see clusters
of students and you might want to work
with them differently and just kind of
know if you're on the bubble you know do
you need to shift them and and so on so
once you have this then the next thing I
do is is I pan alit so in this for
example by section and by subjects I'm
going to use a facet grid from Seaborn
I'm going to map it to the distribution
plot clean it up a bit lose the spines
lose the X tick labels and this is um so
I end up with something like this for
example and this would be we have
section a section B math reading and so
the 5th grade team meets and they say
okay
definitely for section a math and
section b reading we need to
differentiate a bit and prioritize and
pace our instruction a little bit
differently for the different groups and
then I'll iterate so for a school grade
a test and this takes a while right some
time just takes an hour so it's time for
a snack or perhaps a map the function to
make this work out better so when that's
all said and done and in fact just
before I left work today I I ran a boat
I think another 250 charts as it
iterated through all these different
permutations and you know as I was
thinking about it because it really
makes it so the next time around there's
no heavy lifting right I just run the
code and it's there so now you can ask
higher order questions right and you can
ask more interesting questions and you
can make more informed decisions and so
and then the data digs in the sense
making meetings with the school teams
become more informed because they're not
preoccupied was trying to get data and
work with Excel and so you can allocate
your resources better and ask the more
interesting questions so again faster
turnaround time due to automation focus
on more interesting things perhaps
feature extraction or prediction to help
target intervention with students and so
that's how python is really in Pentos
and that Platt Lindsay born and saw has
really helped in our school district
with them asking higher order questions
in saving time thank you
[Applause]
yes so I don't um now it's there's an
incentive especially teacher evaluation
you hope is not going to be something
that that happens but as an economist
you know how incentives work right so we
haven't done anything that sophisticated
our data sets I don't think aren't too
big to really compare but even if they
were it's a good idea
it's of interest but I haven't done
anything I need to though
so next up we have brian luster and his
talk title is getting rid of UNK or
unknowns I say okay so I'm Brian Lister
I'm a sheen line engineer at trove and
mostly we thought we do stuff with
emails so I do a lot of NLP mostly as it
applies to email and so I'm going to
talk about kind of what our work on like
robust models and slightly more
intelligent input representations and
kind of the assumptions that currently
go into input and um so what is uncle
bunky and Elan common words so
especially in deep learning you have a
lot of parameters that you have to fit
so when you only have a word a couple of
times you can't learn a real good
representation so you take UNK and you
use that and so now all these uncommon
words kind of the same representation so
you know a little bit but you don't know
that much and you can see it really
removes a lot of information so these
are excerpts from penn treebank and
wikitext - which are common language
modeling datasets and you can see even
in like one sentence there's like five
monks so obviously you're losing like a
lot of information and unfortunately
you're always going to lose this
information so these are some
statistical facts about language
the first one is called zip slaw which
is essentially for any common word it's
way more common than the next most
common word so really what this means is
you have a very long tail and vocabulary
so there's a lot of very uncommon words
and then on the bottom you see heap slaw
which is essentially as you add more
documents to your data set you're always
going to find more words and so
basically the practical meaning is you
can't truly model language with a closed
vocabulary with UNK there are ways as I
said before about how to keep
information you can do your own before
you train it and so then you learn this
kind of fuzzy meaning for any unknown
word or you could average on common
words together when you have
trained vectors which is that same idea
where all these uncommon words are
probably kind of somewhere so you put
them together but you're still losing a
lot so a smarter way is to use an
open-toe cab you Larry and the most
natural way then is to use characters
which have a close over here plating but
the only real problem with characters is
that there's really two ways to combine
it there's things you have to memorize
like here when you take dad and subtract
the d-mat the B you get bad but there's
no relation to that there's no other
there aren't other words we're
subtracting the D and a D the B turns it
from you know a father figure to
something bad so you really have to
memorize some of that kind of stuff
about characters but there are things
that generalize so this is generally
what you call morphology in linguistics
so car plus s is cars cat possesses cats
the transformation is the same when you
do the same text transformation and now
in email and more like social media
texts you have other forms of morphology
which is I love it versus I love it
where you know all those O's that really
it basically does add meetings and so a
natural model that we're using on this
kind of research development stuff is
analysis team characters because it's
very flexible it can learn a lot but it
can also learn the generalizations that
we want but this isn't a character lsdm
which you may have heard of where you
take an LST m and run it over all the
characters in your sequence and try to
generate characters because that has its
own problems because the average word
and they in English is about five so if
you're trying to model sequence that has
a fancy of like 30 words suddenly your
dependencies like 180 if you include
spaces so already is you can use an LCM
on single words only and then feed that
into whatever your downstream language
model model whatever so this tiny little
ostium which you reuse on every word
it's going to learn basically it'll
create the embedding for the word as
instead of looking it up and an
embedding matrix that you've pre trained
or training the task which is the common
the way most people do it right now
and so here you can really see the
difference where instead of embedding
the whole word into making a matrix you
embed the characters
and then you combine them together but
one unfortunate thing is that you do
lose kind of a lot there's a lot of
information in word embeddings which you
might have heard of with word to vac
where you train these word embeddings on
huge purposes and you get information
out of it you get things like you know
this example Kitty - capitalist August
puppy and you also do see some of the
morphology stuff I talked about earlier
and the reason this happens is because
you have so much data and you see all
these words in so much context but the
again well with these word vectors
they're actually they are trained
separately so even though like the
distance between things that are like
single and they're plural even though
that's pretty similar and you get to do
these analogies the model doesn't
actually know it doesn't understand
that's morphology or somebody can
generalize it just happens because it's
seen things in context so many times
whereas with our LST M we were trying to
actually model those kind of changes in
morphology but even though you lose this
kind of stuff the classical ones you see
and weird effect you actually still can
see it with this kind of model so this
is from a paper from CMU which it's
where we got this idea from you can see
the first two are words that we're in
the training set and they're embedded
with the LST M and then it looks up
basically all the words that have the
closest embeddings to this so you can
see like increased improve expected it's
really that IDI kind of here and this
paper was trained on Wikipedia and so
you see these names are actually all
kings of England which I'm sure is part
of the data and then interestingly these
last two are actually words that are not
in the training set so these are words
that the embedding is created with the
lsdm and you see a lot of these words
that are similar do make sense we hit
the Inge and the last column and in the
third column you see Noah Shire is
clearly going to be similar to like a
city name and we can see all the rest
are actually City games that we're in
the training set so you still do get
these kind of word embeddings
but if you really like word embeddings
or you really want to leverage that huge
amount of data that these word
embeddings are trained on they're
normally on common crawl Google News
that kind of stuff
you could do something like having this
kind of back off we're here if our word
appears less than five times we do our
lsdm to look at it otherwise we take our
word and bedding so this is kind of like
a compromise that lets us leverage like
that big data and then this was just
like some quick experiments I did with
it without too much tuning you can see
kind of the differences where the first
ones just doing the normal word
embeddings which is what everyone does
the second one is this LS TM
compositional model and the third one is
the back off model I just showed you
know these are just my quick experiments
not state of the art or anything but you
can see combination the compositional
model actually outperforms the word one
and it has way less parameters which is
always nice and so kind of future
research with this or over planned U is
hopefully we can use this to build more
robust models especially for things like
named in a recognition where you're
going to run into unknown words a lot
applying the same kind of thing to your
output because right now you at the end
you still have a fixed output if you're
doing language modeling so that's a
little unfortunate you know we can also
leverage this to do pre train to get
kind of the same like really good word
embeddings then there's other options
for some words and such as characters
like since we're trying to capture
morphology if we use a linguistic inform
some words like prefixes and suffixes
that might help and of course there's
smarter ways to combine the characters
at the end with attention or something
similar
[Applause]
so he asked how do we work with
different encoding zazen actually utf-8
latin-1 all that kind of stuff um so our
company runs like an email app which is
where a lot of the data comes from where
we can do a blind you don't actually
look at it but that's all handled by the
actual app team and they all save it to
utf-8 and then I just get to work with
that
Bob's talk title is the imposter
syndrome finishing the Ironman in last
place I get no reveals tonight do I okay
so that's right so what is an Ironman
well I'm not talking about that Ironman
I'm talking about this one which I've
done several times so far by it's a two
point four mile swim followed by a 112
mile bike and a 26.2 mile run I can see
you all looking down at my stomach
that's fine that's the natural thing to
do so I am always the biggest guy out
there when racing and this is a look at
what the swim start looks like and in
the lower corner here you can see that a
2.4 miles swim is essentially going from
swimming from Gallup Park up to that
Island Park so it's it's a long way and
it's a mass start this this here all of
these little dots that are hard to see
that's actually swimmers and up here
this is this is a different swim start
where they started on the beach and I'm
one of those hats you can see and this
is what we call it it's Australian rules
football in a washing machine because
you can swim the shortest line where
everybody's swimming if you want to
fight about it or you can swim a longer
distance off to the side so we do that
to uh you come out of the water
you find your bike sometimes people
hanging balloons and things like that
trying to figure out where their bike is
I was never never had a big problem
because all the bikes are gone by the
time I get there 112 miles on the bike
takes about seven hours you'll see it
pretty much the width of Michigan a
little bit less and and then a little
walk in the park 26.2 miles from
basically somewhere around Brighton to
somewhere around the airport and this is
all in one day and there we go
this was
which one was that Panama City Beach
that would be Florida this is my first
one 13:45 was my finish time and does
that make me an Ironman so what is an
Ironman is the question the race is what
I just told you about an Ironman is a
Mayan Ironman well yeah I am but I don't
know it even today so why wouldn't I be
well I would be back here somewhere
these guys they all swim by me they they
literally lap me the fastest swimmers
come right by I going up a hill when
you're the heaviest guy out there feels
unfair I think everybody should have to
be have to carry the same model weight
as I do nobody agrees with that hard to
get that so everybody's faster than me
on the bike and you can tell by the look
on my face there it's not as easy as it
seems
uh-huh so long painful run blisters and
just not feeling good and again
everybody is faster than me I also the
first time I did Wisconsin I didn't
finish
there's my DNF just disqualified did not
finish that's a bummer my bike broke the
bottom bracket on the bike broke and the
whole pedal assembly would wobble so if
I got in the top chain ring that it
would throw the chain off so like every
10th revolution the chain would come off
so finally I realized if I stayed in the
small gears then I could go but I mean
my you know it's like ok great so I I
made it to the finish but I'd missed the
time cutoff and so they didn't let me do
the run which at that point it was 60
degrees and raining and I didn't really
care at that point I mean I did carry it
hurt my feelings it really did so so why
wouldn't I be an Ironman well maybe I
failed once
these are the metals that I got from
doing all the different Ironman
triathlons I've done so yeah probably an
Ironman I'd say so what I'm really here
to talk about is the imposter syndrome
so I'm a senior developer here at TD
Ameritrade and sometimes I feel like it
and sometimes I spend all day on a bug
and I think you know what somebody's
gonna come over and say you're not a
senior developer you spent all day on
this stupid bug okay ah I like this one
because do you remember the name of the
guy that mr. incredible fought in the
end it was syndrome see what I did there
okay so the imposter syndrome is
something that's real it's in very
technical professions it's more
pronounced because you can't know
everything anymore there's no way so I
you know we look up stuff on Stack
Overflow every day every hour you know
there's a there's a lot I don't know
because you just can't you what what
you're gonna work on tomorrow you might
not have ever seen it before
uh I struggle to solve bugs I spend
hours sometimes days on a bug and you
told your boss hey yeah I'm sure I'll be
done tomorrow you're not gonna be done
tomorrow so maybe you are you get you
get lucky sometimes or sometimes the bug
is really easy and then and then you
feel bad about yourself you're like you
know what I used the wrong object and
that was just a stupid mistake yeah it
happens I
I sit next to Sean LA I sit next to dr.
Sean LA and you know he never makes
mistakes we know this right
but eventually I solved the bugs and
that's why I put the the Ironman logo
there because I want to remind myself
that that yeah I'm gonna struggle
everyone's gonna struggle it doesn't
seem that easy I mean it seems easy when
someone else is doing it you talked to
somebody in there like oh I
this thing together and it just I just
did this and I did that like wow that's
really cool
they don't tell you about how you spent
time so back to the Iron Man
I was running in Wisconsin the second
time that I did the race and I ran past
a cop and my face red
just just had the shuffle going on the
marathon shuffle going on and the cop
said hey man are you okay I said man if
I feel this bad on my second loop I want
you to shoot me
this is a true story 13 miles later
hours later I come shuffling by same cop
puts his hand on his guns how you
feeling I had I had a time during the
Ironman in Florida where I was down at
myself there's parts in every race you
know a race that takes up to 16 hours 17
hours you're gonna have a bad day at
some point like you're gonna blow a flat
you're gonna you're just not gonna eat
enough you're not gonna drink enough
it's gonna be too hot too cold doesn't
matter something's gonna go wrong and I
was down you know what I got kids I'm
too old for this kind of thing I'm a
heaviest guy out here the winners have
already finished that the winners would
finish the race before I would get to
the run before I started the Ironman the
the winners coming in the other way nine
hours no problem and he's not even
sweating he didn't even have the decency
to sweat so I was gonna quit I was I was
done and this little tiny girl she might
have been
I know 20 years old 100 pounds tops she
came right up running by she said come
on we're gonna be an Ironman let's go
soon we are said yeah all we gotta do is
run we got like nine more miles to go
I'm like we had nine miles to go sleep
we've done a hundred and thirty-eight
miles so far like you can't quit now
yeah you know you're right and so I
started running and I got my medal you
saw that the picture and the bottom line
is is that in your day to day you're
gonna find those times where you want to
quit and your body's gonna tell you your
friends are gonna tell you
you know just move on to something else
you'll get through it so how much time I
get I'm okay actually why don't I take
some questions first of all show of
hands anyone else imposters anyone lying
about it supporting others I tell that
story really no I honestly do
yeah I think I think we need to support
each other all the time when someone you
can tell when someone's really getting
there by kick you know you make a joke
to someone who's normally laughing and
they're just like not now like hey you
know what's going on take you know we
got these ping-pong tables back here we
got foosball sometimes you just walk
away and you know you sometimes you go
home go to bed get a good night's sleep
you come into where I'm worrying you're
like ah this isn't hard you've been
banging your head in the desk for hours
and so so a lot of times just walk away
for a few minutes and go find something
to laugh about
go on youtube find a joke you know and
and yeah this I would give that advice
every time tell people that that you're
gonna get through you deserve to be here
youyou got iured you know I assume that
everyone's getting better every day
right you're learning stuff so when they
hired you they said you're good enough
to do this job and you've been learning
every day since then so yeah you're you
may be struggling today but tomorrow
you'll get through it so yeah anyone
else you know in a wetsuit you could sit
on my back and I wouldn't sink so so in
triathlon we wear a wetsuit because it's
much faster through the water but also
it's much safer you but they do they do
have they have had some tragedies but
they tend to they have scuba divers
around the corners like when you go
around the there's a big six-foot tall
balloon
like a pyramid-shaped balloon yeah and
everyone kind of even if you were
swimming way over there they come in so
they'll put divers down their kayaks all
over the place it should never have a
turret tragedy but it does occasionally
but but yeah if you it only it's only a
tragedy if you panic because you can
literally just stop moving and you'll
float like a cork so
[Applause]
this is healthy Kumari and the title of
our talk is machine learning for
exploratory research in information
science cool hi so until feek I'm a PhD
student at the University of Michigan I
screw up information I study parenting
online and there's only like a few of us
worldwide so that's awesome I'm going to
present the contents of a paper that we
submitted recently to the Chi the big
it's like the biggest basically computer
interaction conference and it studies
how parents are using pseudonymous
social media sites specifically or
reddit which is awesome got a check
reddit if you're banging your head
against broke against the problem spend
ten minutes there alright so just a
quick go to the the theory here so
basically pseudonymous sites a lot of
people to talk about things that might
be you know stigmatizing they don't want
to talk about them when they're using
their real names and there were a couple
of papers that looked at anonymous
websites for moms where they basically
go there and just talk about everything
they don't want to talk about when
they're they're real using the real IDs
same deal care happens with dads and so
that's one of the papers that i had
published and it was like these
Sudama social media sites especially
when they're recently divorced when
there are single dads or if they're gay
but like LGBTQ parents in general do
like to use Sudama signature sites
particularly if they're living in places
that are not very welcoming
sometimes rural areas okay so we won't
test in two main research questions what
topics do parents discuss on
pseudonymous social media sites online
and are there any differences between
mom centered and dad centered online
social media use okay so this is just a
quick look at the rise in the use of
parenting subreddits basically parenting
that's a big one and then there's dead
it for dads and mom it for moms okay
and so this is the banner for each one
of them this is parenting this is mom it
and this one here is dead it okay and so
what we tried to do was basically and by
the way people do cross post so we will
find people who posted netted and
parenting and then dead it and mama
but there this is proportional so mostly
between the cross-posting is between mom
and parenting dad and parenting but
sometimes also crosses between them what
we did was an aggregate LD a model for
all of them but since parenting is the
biggest we wanted to also flesh out the
differences of a tail out of Namit and
dad it so we did an independently a
model for mom it independent one Ford
edit but we also thought that sometimes
maybe we might get similar topics from
mahmud and edits and so to compare them
we also ran independent vert effect
models on both of these sub reddits and
we basically took the the the topic
models and created topic similarities
using Jack out similarities so basically
we multiplied a card similarity between
the topic so this is an example topic
mom dad parent and the comment moms and
dads tried to do the best for their
children the score would be the jackpot
similarity between them both in this
care in case one over for all right so
let's go and see how our research
questions panned out so the first one is
about what the topics were the parents
were discussing on pseudo I want to see
social media sites like Reddit and how
aren't they discussed in the different
the three different sub reddits that I
showed you mom and dad and parenting so
these are the main topics birth
milestones transition to teen years
discipline or abuse that's a common
question judgment playing competition
purchase suggestions faith and family
and online interactions in general so
turns out by the way that like I'm not a
parent how many how many here are
parents I I don't know how you guys do
it it looks like a really difficult
thing to do everyone is is asking
questions and it appears as though no
one knows exactly what they're doing but
it's it's so one of the things that we
found for example we can do is measure
where some of the topics are more dense
so for examples fleet training happens
to be denser with mom it the mom
subreddit and dad but less so in
parenting as you can see same thing same
deal with breastfeeding that make sense
for example with milestones we start
seeing something interesting here
milestones themselves so this is about
like when should my son start like
talking or walking etc that's again mom
and dad have more of a concentration
here but once you start talking about
teen talk and discipline the discussion
starts moving to parenting that's the
major subreddit the major parenting
subreddit and one of the things we move
to notice there is that the breakdown
here is not based on gender it's based
on how you think of things like what's
your parenting philosophy as a parent
are you disciplinarian do you want them
to take it on their own pace that's the
break up there so it's kind of moved
into the parenting subreddit this one is
kind of interesting because one of the
things we found constantly with online
with fathers online is that they want to
provide support for each other and so if
we look at like how one of the things
that happens is that there's like a
congratulatory post welcome to that it
welcome to mahmud and if you look here
like that it is basically the densest
one they have lots of things that's like
hey welcome congratulations and having
your first kid now we want to discuss
again how do they break down when we go
to dad and mom and specifically what are
the differences there and so again we
did the different allele models
independent available and all for the
work effect and here the the the father
centric ones NICU experiences
particularly because mom is usually
still in the hospital as well legal
custody questions and experiences
language here it gets really colorful
and Halloween which is kind of weird but
yeah all right mother centric it's about
the child waking so in especially in the
first few months recovering from birth
and losing pregnancy weight and finally
maintaining the home with it with a
young child now I said there were common
topics that would come up from the
different the two independently a model
and these are four of them food
preparation circumcision vaccines and
naming naming the child so challenge for
the food preparation one of the
interesting things that dads focus more
on snacks just like they're preparing
food at a later age moms talk a lot
about like pureed food solids vegetables
when you start like introducing soil to
its texture
with circumcision as might be expected
dads are focused on just their sons
right circumcision moms on the other
hand are focused on female genital
mutilation they talk about societal
factors so it's a bit different with
vaccines we found something that's kind
of weird and that moms for example focus
a lot on diseases statistics MMR vaccine
for toes etcetera with that the first
one that comes up the closest words to
the word vaccine is HPV and so there's a
lot of talk about HPV vaccine STDs that
kind of sort of that sort of thing and
that comes out of the word Tyvek model
finally naming naming is kind of
interesting so both of them talk about
nicknames pronunciations and then
there's the you know the the link with a
cultural aspect irish or somebody's in
the data chinese for some reason with
Mahmut we're not sure but the
interesting one with that it was
stripper but then we found that there
were like few threads on that it
specifically like opening question as to
whether or not that name is a stripper
name and turns out that later lots of
rules and whether or not the they name
ended with an i or a why made all the
difference and so that's you know that's
an interesting thing that i didn't think
about for now i show this because now we
we did submit this paper and i'm not
sure i'm still under review but one of
the things that we faced one of the
problems we faced is that once you run
the LDA topic it's very difficult to
actually say what the ground truth is
because we don't have one that's why
we're running gale day that's when we
were doing this this study in the first
place so how do we kind of provide for
any reader some sort of way to actually
trust our topic mostly one of the things
we did was we basically randomly went
through as many of the topics as we
could see that it makes sense made sense
to us but there's very difficult way to
actually do it objectively using
objective metrics one metric because use
we you can use with with lDA's
perplexity but there is a paper out
there that says doesn't work for
perplexity
levels could be really good but then it
doesn't really make sense to you the
reader so one of the things we're
thinking about later is running it
through enter and seeing if if we can
get an average that makes sense that
people say yeah that topic makes sense
to me
but if anyone has run similar techniques
it would be great to talk after this
same deal with word Tyvek so we've found
that were - that could be used to like
to find differences between if the same
topics are coming up in two different
places online but I'm also one I also
want to know if there are other ways to
use word to that in exploratory research
[Applause]
rather than in general yes but part of
the problem is that we don't know what
the makeup of these subreddits are in
reddit in general I think it's a roughly
60 to 40 e mail and that's a study by
pew so yes thank you so next up is
Clayton Yocum and his title is taught is
teaching our Python and cleanness also
organizes the our meetup in town meetup
so my name is Clayton Yocum and like
Sean said I'm gonna be talking about
ditching our for Python and algorithmic
trading if you know me you know that I'm
a huge are nerd and so ditching is
certainly too strong of a term I don't
think I could ever fully ditch are even
for you know one project but I think
anything a little more truthful or
realistic would have made a much more
boring title so home by I'm a data
science engineer at methods consultants
which is a small consulting firm in
Ypsilanti Michigan so not too far from
here I like Sean said I co organize the
Ann Arbor our user group and so if like
me you love our or if you don't love our
and you were just curious about it
please come to our
meet up we've got one on Thursday at
SPARC just downtown like two blocks from
here
Kenny are ya kiddin ya like a half a
block from here that's right
I co maintain now this like our drop to
package for using Dropbox from our so
this is just kind of give you a sense
like I'm really kind of in this this our
world die hard our fan just - and I'm
really not a Python user I at a previous
job like four years ago
I especially because I think the tools
for doing this in are much harder I need
to do some web scraping and so use
Python and beautifulsoup like I don't
know two or three I think someone told
me today they're they're up to
beautifulsoup for so I'm sure it's like
even easier in Python than it used to be
but you know I am by no means a Python
user especially when you think about
kind of the the data science or the
scientific computing stack you know the
the pandas and the side pie and the
numpy like that's really not my my bag
but you'll see that I end up using it
anyways so in my work at this consulting
firm one of my big clients is a hedge
fund right I guess he's like a former
hedge fund manager but now is like maybe
going to be a future hedge fund manager
I don't know exactly what to call him
but he's this finance guy and he's got
this large pile of very painstakingly
curated data that is you know very very
proprietary very very valuable I'm not
gonna really get to show you any of the
details here but the idea is that he's
got all this data and he's like for this
sub segment of the market I think these
are the important indicators they're
gonna help me make money determining you
know when to buy and when to sell people
in this market stocks in this market
segment but he especially I think we're
well over 200 different features and
that's before you consider feature
engineering and doing things like
leading and lagging you know all the
different things you can do to kind of
manipulate your data to allow you to
build better models without some sort of
statistical or machine learning kind of
approach it's it's difficult if not
impossible to really
build a good robust model given all of
these things that you think have you
know kind of different levels of value
to them and so that's why he's come to
us to turn this kind of pile of data
that he knows to have some value or
things to have some value in it turns
out it's insanely valuable but he wants
us to help him turn that into a trading
strategy and and the hard part of the
easy part can be building a trading
strategy the hard part is telling if
that strategy is actually any good
because it's very easy and I think that
I would probably say 99.9% of like oh
look I'm like using some software
engineering or some machine learning to
like make money in the stock market
most of those yeah almost all of those
strategies are not going to work very
long don't do things like accounting for
Commission's or slippage or accounting
for um selection bias season and data
leakage when you're trying to do a back
test to see if a strategy is any good
and so that ends up really being the
hardest part of my work in this project
is like okay we came up with a strategy
it seems to work but how confident are
we that it's actually going to work that
it's going to continue working then it
would have worked in the past you know
had we how do we come up with it
previously and like I said I can't
really show you much detail and my
slides here are actually very boring
it's not because I wrote them in our
although I did write them in our it's
because I was putting out fires all day
at work and didn't have much time to
repair the slides but the process just
at a very high level you would have this
raw data that this guy has provided or
his team has provided generates some
sort of clean features from that feed
that into one or more models to make
predictions and these could be simple
linear models these could be deep neural
nets anywhere anything in between I'm a
big fan of like tree based models so I
end up doing like random forests and
gbm's anywhere that kind of makes sense
because they're always impressively
performant we take these predictions and
then we make picks and so there are
different constraints on what we want
our set of picks to look like but we
might say we want a certain number of
Long's which means we are going to to
buy them a
that the vet are hoping that the value
is going to go up over some period of
time we might have a certain number of
shorts we want so we say which is just
the opposite of long meaning that it's a
stock that you think is going to go down
in value and so you can do things to
make money from that but then once we
just have a set of picks where it's like
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna go long on
these 10 and short on these 10 there's
also an additional step where you
calculate what sizes of positions you
actually want to take those Long's and
shorts in and once you've done all of
those steps for any number of days for a
strategy you might be considering
implementing then you have to evaluate
that and you do some kind of day-by-day
evaluation but you're also evaluating
this thing over a long period of time
and so I've been working on this project
for I think about a year and a half
basically the entire time that I've been
at methods and I wrote a ton of custom R
code because that's my tool that's what
I know that's what I was already
building these models in and I ended up
starting to build like quite a large
back testing framework so that I can say
you know plug these models in plug these
additional functions for turning
predictions to pics to to actual
positions taken each day and you know do
some kind of kind of do that over time
and and generate some different metrics
about how that strategy has would have
done it's just an unbelievable amount of
code that I wrote just like custom R
code and it's just me writing it for the
most part you know there's a couple
other people to put some eyes on it but
it's really you know there's there's
hardly any tests which is which is on me
you know I could have I could have
tested it better as I was building it
but it's it's there's also limited
functionality because I'm building this
very kind of bespoke back testing
platform around exactly the way that I
have defined the problem which isn't
necessarily the right way or the best
way to define the problem it's something
that I'm kind of continually learning
and redefining the problem as I've as
I've gone through this because I do not
have a finance background I have like an
undergrad degree in math and like a
little minor and econ but you know that
doesn't prepare you for any of this kind
of stuff so it's been a lot of like
learning over the last year and a half
as to how this needs to work
but pi day to meet up here in July this
guy Gus Gordon from quanto pian
hopefully some of you guys will actually
show a hands was anybody here for Gus
Gordon's talk in July yeah so I thought
it was a really good talk and
particularly I was very impressed by the
tools that he was talking about so
cuanto pian is this very interesting
quantitative or this like trading
platform where you can build your own
algorithms put them on quant opions like
platform and if it does well like
they'll give you money to use it with
their money like to put their capital
behind it and give you a cut but what
was really interesting to me was all of
the open source tools that are literally
just on github that they used to run
quanto peein in the background and so
there's three of them that he talked
about alpha lens zipline and pi folio
I'm gonna kind of skip alpha lens
because I haven't been focusing on that
one too much but basically zipline helps
you run a backtest and pi folio helps
you look at the results of a back test
to see if it was any good or not and I
was really impressed at just how like
how similar how the way that he was
describing the way these libraries
worked is like oh I think that's what I
would have built in another two years
after I like failed a bunch over the
next couple of years and so I started
thinking like maybe I should use these
tools that other people have built that
are more significantly more you know
battle-tested unit tested and you know
have like real money trading on them all
the time and so they were doing a much
better job solving the same kind of
problems and I started digging into that
world which again is like kind of first
forays in Python in years and years and
so I start by just kind of generating
all the same back test data using all my
R code that I was but now I'm using PI
folio to tell me if those are any good
and so that'll generate a lot of the
same metrics that I was generating like
simple things like Alpha Beta Sharpe
ratio but it also does about a half a
dozen others and if you do a full tear
sheet it's like probably 30 plus plots
which is really incredible and I use zip
line to turn then I started kind of
going back and using zip line to turn my
predictions which I did not spell
correctly into into these eval
results that you then pass into pi folio
and like I said I haven't really used
alpha lens yet but even now I'm still
doing it half and half and I think
that's okay you know there's there's a
lot of code that's kind of not worth
burning to the ground that I've built up
in our over the last year and also
running the predictions along with the
the zip line back test would actually
take too long so what I end up doing is
kind of generating the predictions in
one set and then taking those
predictions and running those through
zip line very quickly which also allows
me to kind of play with some of the
smaller parameters of how the strategy
works but I get all these benefits like
I said battle-tested code way more
metrics and plots a nice decoupling of
building my prediction for my strategy
and there's a couple of big kind of
hurdles that I had here Python is quite
different from our mixed code bases are
not not the best thing ever
also I don't know if anybody here is an
hour user or uses the tiny verse I think
pandas is great but I think the tidy
verse is like this things like deep liar
in the MiG McGruder pipe way better way
better than pandas and also I think it's
ridiculous that if I take one of my
numpy vectors or columns out of pandas
and just take one object out of it that
all of a sudden it's a different type I
think that that is that gets me every
time and really annoys the hell out of
me
so what's next another another talk that
they that was given I think actually
before the quanto bian one was his tool
called pachyderm which is for building
kind of language independent
containerized data workflows and that's
actually how i'm gonna build out the
next iteration of our platform to allow
me to backtest much more easily into
backtest kind of quicker and oh yes I'm
the first one to hit the limit that is
awesome
docker containers everywhere
and so the next speaker is Alex kale and
the original title of his talk was
something about connected vehicles yeah
so hello hello you're me I'm Alex when
my job is working for the University of
the Transportation Research Institute on
North Campus today I'll be talking about
connected vehicle data so so for those
who don't know Ann Arbor and the
University of Michigan is running is one
of the leaders and connected vehicle or
not I made it vehicle research there is
deployment in the area of about a
thousand of 3,000 vehicles depending on
who you ask
with automated or not automated with
connected vehicle data that we're
collecting every single day from regular
people like you and me and trucks and
buses around here so this is talking
about that data here so part of my my
reason I want to talk about this is try
to crowdsource a solution to a problem
that we've been dealing with and come as
far as I know that no one has really
solved yet which is how to privatize or
protect data that we're getting from
connected vehicles while making it
useful to researchers so depending on
who you talk to so connected vehicle
data in case you're not aware of it it's
just basically GPS data so you get
lat/longs
you get people's speeds headings a bunch
of identifiers about the cars and stuff
so that's basically what it is there's
no and then so the whole point of
connected vehicle technology is you
broadcast that information to other
vehicles nearby so they know what you're
doing where you're heading hopefully in
the future whether you're going to turn
or not stuff like that so so that that's
the data that's being useful for
researchers so some people are concerned
about the privacy of a connective your
code data
some like my boss are worried that you
know we share that data with the public
than people who know where you live and
work and some people don't want to know
that personally I don't think that's a
big deal because you know I think that
it's already public information we've
linked in and other data sources on the
web that you can find out freely but to
other people that's also a big deal also
so but there's other places you also go
with your car that some might consider a
private or not private you know the
supermarket
some people might hear it you know
whether you're shopping liar or Walmart
or what schools you go to your kids go
to other stuff so we're trying to come
up with a solution to make this data
useful while still protecting people's
privacy for all for all levels so
another similar data set that we
currently have I know I don't know how
many of you guys are familiar with the
New York City Taxi data set is anyone
familiar with that
so basically New York City really has
the data set on all taxi fares in the
city of New York for and a couple years
so the data they have it or the drop-off
points pick up points what taxi it is
how much the fare was how much the
passenger tips and all that so it's a
little bit different they only have the
endpoints they don't show you what route
they actually took in the car but just
from this fuel piece of information some
hackers were able to identify you know
which celebrity to a certain trip just
like looking up gossip magazines finding
photo basically I think they didn't
describe it exactly but I think what
they did was they looked up photos of
celebrities and taxis in New York City
they didn't actually care what celebrity
was basically the Google Det found an
image no read the corresponding article
to figure out what day it was and tired
of the location so once they have the
day location an approximate time
then they can go into the New York City
Taxi database or data set and look up
and try to find that corresponding fear
so basically they were able to find it
for you know Bradley Cooper you're just
Kyle Bob you know figure out where they
were going where they ended up and then
basically they're dueling and how much
they tipped you know that allows
basically the gold I mean but I mean it
was just for fun but I mean they
basically you know found so basically
you know that's sort of innovation of
privacy depending you know how you view
it right so you know with that little
information they were able to figure out
but you know the other thing that I
wasn't sure is whether they were
actually correct you know there could
have been two trips or three trips that
could have matched that profile and they
just picked the wrong one right because
there's no ground truth and you know
this data set you know they're just
doing their best guessed all right so
that's part of the issue we have so
currently there's a couple of different
algorithms that you know that's been
brought up about how to protect the
privacy so the goal is basically I think
most people agree is you want you want
to protect the endpoints of your trips
without making the data useless does
that make sense right so here I've
created four trips on Google Maps from
four different disc nations and then the
end points or the start point here it is
TD Ameritrade right so this is what you
know the data would look like you know
you have your four trips you have points
along the way and then you know you have
the route and starting endpoint so the
question is how can we escape the
endpoints to high that you know our home
or our workplaces TD Ameritrade all
right so one so the most common method
that people can think of is use a
distance based algorithm where you off
escape the ending based on some distance
from the endpoint so it's sort of so I
just did this by hand but basically sort
of looks like this once you apply dagger
into through these four trips so
basically what you get unfortunately and
you basically end up with
a circle around the centroid which is
the destination of choice so that's not
agreed everything might view so another
one is Oh skip this flag alright so I'll
just talk so another one another
algorithm is just to do the time base so
you lop off some random time portion
from the beginning or end of the trip
and then that will make it more random
jaggedness around the destination but
then there's also issues with time based
algorithms similar to distance space and
then another algorithm that people
hazardous so this is what sort of the
time being cutoff would look like so you
know you have your points a little bit
it won't be as circular as a distance
based algorithm but it's still sort of
you know centroid ish around around the
destination point so the last so far is
sort of like a map based algorithm where
basically you take the end point and you
take the route and then you cut off the
end point up to say a major intersection
like a four-way stop or a three-way stop
where the options to continue that trip
or multitude or high multitude and then
high in multi-dimensions so you know
there's more than whatever a lot of
options that they could have done so it
becomes less clear about where they were
ending up or where they started from but
in order to that you need to know
something about the road network and
Road classifications and residential
areas and all that so you know if you're
driving into Old West Side you might you
know you don't and you know if you want
to hide them within the old west side
you know you might want to cut them off
like liberty and ashley our liberty and
first word you know that's sort of like
the the gateway into the whole west side
right so that's a comment so that's a
relatively new algorithm but i still
don't think that's exactly perfect so
basically my worry is that you know so
there's sort of two sorts of hacking you
can do one is that a if i know this
person is in this data set
how do i identify them and i think based
on just thinking about it that we girls
is hunger the algorithm is eventually i
think they'll be able to figure out who
you are in that data set no just you
know if they know something about your
patterns or where you live and work you
know they can figure out well what's the
usual routes you can take you know
regardless regardless of endpoints right
the heart the other questions that i
think is easier or to privatise whose
life there is this data set but who's in
the data set like i don't know anybody
in the data set how can identify people
that that's nothing easier to office
kate alright so basically we're you know
depending on the algorithm we're doing a
good job or but bad job
last thing i want to say so as i said we
have a current deployment if you're
interested in joining and having your
car joined us study you can go here and
sign up and for those so you don't know
the university of michigan is deploying
an autonomous shadow on North Campus
later this month or next month it'll be
free to put or not the public free to
you of them and you can probably just
hop on
[Music]
you
[Applause]
regu will be talking to us about
improving access using interaction and
analysis via bouquet an engineer's story
so just to give you a background I'm new
to Python and most of the work I do is
in C++ photon or MATLAB and my current
company is patent Miller and we are into
Motorsports
and what we try to do is like what I'm
trying to I was trying to look for a
tool which will make it easy for
multiple multiple people to look at and
analyze so for example if you have plot
in MATLAB if I send it to someone else
who is at a racetrack he doesn't he
needs to open matlab and basically
interact with it
so in my case like i noticed like there
are a lot of beautiful visualizations
which are made by python so i thought
any Python will be a good place to start
making interactive tool which is
portable so HTML is one of the format's
which plotly or bouquets developed in I
mean like the output so that you can
just this gives us ability to basically
gather data or visualize and analyze
data in real time people can zoom in
zoom out select data remove data points
and by the in greater detail so now the
two versions I looked at was one was
broadly the sure I follow found was like
it did not have a callback option so
what we are trying to do is like trying
to see how parameters changing
parameters in a function influences the
plot basically so partly he did not have
the callback feature so that was an
issue but boquete had a callback option
so it seemed like good to go cats exist
wanted to
so there's the slightest example on
bouquet basically you can choose phase
frequency you can basically toggle move
this slider and change the plot this has
I don't have internet connection I
cannot show it to you but yeah so this
is my actual implementation so we have
like close to 20 parameters and we do a
lot of playing around with the data set
in terms of like what is the fastest
speed you can gain or what is its
lateral force you can generate at a
corner so using this like a race
engineer or anyone someone who is
playing around with the data can see the
influence of maybe a weight of the
vehicle what camber they're like how the
tires are aligned on the Quaker how it
influences so the plot you are saying is
very crucial for finding out like how we
have different diameters influence
vehicle handling or vehicle dynamics
so basically my goal for this talk was
like just trying to explore like trying
to find some help so that's why I came
over here to find out like is if I'm
focused on the right tool or should I be
looking at another tool so even if even
if I have developed this application in
boquete it still has some limitations I
need to use Python and anaconda in
conjunction so somebody using it in a
remote location needs to install this
and run this application by a Python
compiler so I wanted to know if there is
if there is a way I can create a
standalone application and it's not a
possibility otherwise like I was
thinking like if Python or bouquet
server can be combined with taken to
speak into Gaea interface for Python but
I found out like I have forums like it's
not a possibility because it uses
JavaScript so I'm thinking should I
continue with Python or like if you have
any suggestions or advice I'd appreciate
it
there's my lightning
[Applause]
last but not least we have Vinson
Russell who will be telling us about
stage mathematical research and time
permitting also he'll be talking about
Plex agent coding okay so I'm Vincent
Russell I did my undergraduate degree at
University of Michigan oh thank you how
about that okay so I did my
undergraduate degree at University of
Michigan and recently I graduated from
Clemson University with a master's
degree the 2017 champs of the football
my area study was number theory and one
of the things I did in number theory was
I used something called sage which is
based primarily at numpy Tsai PI and
many other applications of Python and
the nice part about it is you can code
python right in sage so if you do some
algorithms on mathematical analysis you
can use Python to to loop through you
know quadratic extensions of number
fields and whatnot in number theory so
that what I was interested in was
modular forms Eagle modular forms and L
functions so if you don't know what a
modular form is well the time of Yama is
more of a conjecture if you're familiar
with photography elliptic curves are
modular forms and it looked at curves
play a crucial role in modern
cryptography so like I said it has the
applications to cryptography my research
does and that usually goes through
what's called El functions that when you
attach a modular form to an L function
you get a product expansion called a
Euler product or the product that gives
a product of prime numbers so by
understanding modular forms and L
functions we can understand prime
numbers better and when you understand
prime numbers better you can understand
cryptography better and you know the
discrete logarithm problem becomes
easier so what we want to do is we want
to consider the upper half plane where
this is a complex number field where X
plus iy y is greater than zero when X Y
is an element of the real numbers so
it's this shaded area up here it's a
subset of complex numbers
what we want to do is we want to extend
this definition to higher dimensions so
where I was particularly concerned with
H to cross H 2 and H 4 this is a fourth
degree and those are two two degrees and
so H n if you were looking at four then
this is a matrix of four by four matrix
with elements in the complex numbers
where Z is symmetric and Y is positive
definite those are matrices so we
consider what's called Z --gel pull
backs of modular forms two particular
dimensions and this was computed before
my research by Dominic Lanfear of h1
cross h1 and h2 and h1 cross h2 and h3
so what I did was I computed
h2 across h2 and age four and like I
said this gives you that we don't have
many computations of Z go modular forms
yet they're generalities of modular
forms so if we can compute more modular
forms we can understand prime numbers
and many very various things in number
theory that would help greatly our
understanding of like the Penguins
problem and many other certain things so
I did this they dominantly I'm fear
computed all this by hand I use sage in
Python to write code based on an
algorithm written in a shamora paper who
was the name that I said earlier the
tiny Amish more of a conjecture which
was famous in the proof of Fermat's Last
Theorem back in 1996 so basically what H
to cross h2 in h4 means is these are
three dimensional vector spaces and so
you have a six dimensional space
embedded into a 10 dimensional space so
the way you can analyze this or an
analogy to this is if you have a line in
three dimensions you have an X Y Z
coordinate but the line itself is a one
surface it's a one dimensional surface
you know it's just back and forth so we
consider a six dimensional service
living in ten dimensional space so the
puzzle piece is to compute for these
pullbacks is that we need to understand
in special embeddings of matrices and
these matrices are have really nice
symmetric properties that when you
transform a function or
elliptic curve they give you nice
results symmetrically on the other side
of the planar and the other part of the
dimension and so by understanding the
symmetries we're going to understand the
functions better so that's why we
transform these these functions so one
other thing we need to understand
another thing we need to understand is
that there's these things called double
coset representatives so this is a
symplectic group and it's it's just
basically matrix multiplication you're
your left multiplying it by something
called a parabolic group and then your
right right multiplying it by this
embedding and this embedding is it's
easier in even dimensions and it is not
because even has a nice structure on the
diagonals when you embed them so in this
we're just doing a left multiplication
right multiplication and what we're
doing in a representative is that you
might have different matrices that when
you multiply them by another matrices in
this group it comes out to the same
result so what we call those two
matrices that multiply each other to get
the same result as we call them
equivalent not equal but equivalent and
so this multiplication ran through the
permutations of the general structure of
the matrices will create equivalence
classes and those can be represented by
the double Co set representative so what
happens is when you computed the the H
to cross H to Co set representatives you
have four Co set represents that's all
you need just four and there there are
simple matrices really but the algorithm
was tough to compute and nobody had put
it into code yet another thing you need
to understand is something called an
isotropy group so when you're moving
from six dimensions to ten dimensions
you want to find out what parts of those
functions are stable or invariant under
the transformation what remains is the
same so that way you can map back and
forth without loss of data so another
thing that you may need to consider I
didn't have to luckily and neither did
Dominic linfer is a change of basis
basically in a vector space you have
functions that make up the whole vector
space any combination you know
multiplying by a constant or something
like that will change the vector space
so finally you want to solve we saw
the pullback of the degree from or for
modular form by using the puzzle pieces
in some numbers here save some numbers
here because it took me like eight
months but I didn't want to really get
into details about that um so what's
what's the big data problem here is that
for different values in the higher
dimensions such as h1 cross H to cross H
2 and H 5 or this one the puzzle pieces
are similar not identical but the puzzle
is always different so you have all
these pieces and you have to do a lot of
manipulation by hand to figure out how
do we fit these pieces together to
create the puzzle or the pullback and so
there's one approach theoretical
approach is using an advanced integral
over a coset space which uses a Rankine
Selberg convolution which is advanced
mathematics but it has really nice
properties which come out in l functions
actually so my solution I should say
that solution but possible solution is
to generate a lot of data I wrote all
this code to generate the cosets
isotropy groups the embeddings and I
wrote it for general any dimension
embeddings so I just I had access to the
palmetto server cluster in Clemson and I
had it for a couple months so I computed
all interesting embeddings I say
interesting because if you look at h1
cross h2 we knew what that was already
that was computed so that would be an h3
so by knowing what we have already H 1
cross H 1 H 1 cross H 2 and H 2 cross H
2 I generated interesting of endings
basically it's all these embeddings into
a higher dimension and I generated 4
degree 1077 all the combinations of
interesting embeddings of that sort and
so I ended up with I think over a
terabyte of data and so what I plan on
doing that what everybody did it didn't
go into my thesis I didn't have room for
it but up in the upcoming year I hope to
use Python visualization code to try and
search for patterns within this data if
we can find patterns in this data we
might have we
shed light on the Riemann hypothesis
which is a famous 150 160 70 I don't
know how many years now 170 I think your
old problem yet it's it's the pinnacle
it's I mean it's a pinnacle of
mathematical research if you can solve
this you names mathematicians are never
on the front of New York Times but you
will be if you solve that so I don't
know how much time I have left but
really quickly what I did over the
summer after I graduated is uh I I used
the great courses which is these
distinguished professors from around the
country give lectures and it's a
something that you can download so
here's an example of a great course it's
number theory there's you know you can
download them where you can stream them
they contain a lot of metadata so here's
a metadata there's lecture names
there's the lecture information and so
what I did was I needed a way to
organize my I have a lot of great
courses because I watch them in my spare
time and there's 30 minutes long and I'd
like to be better at jeopardy so I try
to focus on things that like mythology
and Pope's and all that stuff but I
needed a way to organize and plex allows
you to code these agents so I coded
something called tgc bundle which pulls
data from their website and populates
plex it uses HTML parser to parse the
course webpage for metadata and handle
the Unicode characters I actually found
code from Aaron Schwartz that allowed
really easy manipulation of unicode
characters into the into intraplex I
also use beautifulsoup because it's it's
much easier than HTML parser it's two
lines and you can find what you need in
a web page
you are you are Lib to regular
expressions to create a search algorithm
because Plex reads the file names and so
if the file name isn't exactly what the
course name is you need a way to search
the website for to find the course name
for that and there's also you can add a
course number and that that's a unique
identifier to record so that will always
find it an SSL to handle the SSL
handshake with the website so
the features are matching based on
course number or partial course title
I'm in polls course description lecture
name cover our background our subject
lectures a bunch of stuff and it
populates Plex so here's an example of
some of my courses and that's it so
[Applause]
again all the speakers